at Number 17 George Bryan from Missouri
is about to get a very special birthday
surprise oh that's nice happy birthday
oh my god and for your birthday present
the gift of no I browse whoa whoa whoa
indeed but what cause this cake Inferno
time to get the blow down from our
scientists this fireball happened
because of the powdered sugar that was
layered all over the top the cake and
this is because there's loads of energy
locked up in the chemical bonds of the
sugar molecules it's pretty difficult to
set fire to a sugar cube or even a pile
of powdered sugar the reason that this
reaction is so explosive is because of
the fact that the powdered sugar has
been blown into the air
this means the powdered sugar now has a
really big surface area that it's in
contact with oxygen in the air and it
also comes into contact with the flames
of the candle to get the big fireball we
see in the video we need one more factor
be the sugar particles to be really
close together so that when one ignites
it can catch its neighbor on fire which
can catch its neighbor on fire and we
get a chain reaction and with the heat
from the flame boom
so in George's case the chemistry was
just the icing on a cake